thank you
uh thanks a lot my name is manuel
zabatakis i'm sorry for not being able
to join physically this very nice event
i will be in berkeley in a few min in a
few days so
we can
chat with everybody that's interested in
my work
today i'm going to talk about the
general equilibrium computation and the
foundations of multi-agents machine
learning
so in the in classical
machine learning environments
and in particular in deep learning
um
we have the following oversimplified
view
that has a remarkable progress which is
that we have a single objective function
that can be expressed as a
loss function involving some complicated
neural net
and
we run some
simple procedure to optimize this
function from data and in particular we
usually run
granted send or stop its stochastic
variants and our empirical findings is
that
in several learning settings
uh this gradient descent or the
consent discover local minima
that generalized very well
but now uh let's think about the more
complicated setting a multi-agent
learning setting where instead of having
a single
neural network and the single objective
function to minimize we have several
objects several neural networks
and the
actions of our neural network affect the
utility functions of the rest of the
real networks
and then each one of these
neural networks around their own local
optimization procedure and we want to
see whether this system
converges to something meaningful
and
the practical experience that we have is
that if each one of these neural
networks and individually run gradient
sent
then this system has have have has a
hard time to converge
and
even if it converges it's not clear if
it converges to something meaningful
and the question first question to ask
is how deep is this issue
the simplest is the simplest example of
this issue is already in
two agent settings
and
in particular in two agents and zero sum
games which is
called also min max
optimization uh if we run 20 decent
asset dynamics in this setting
which is what we usually do in
for example in gun training
then
empirically we often observe in practice
some cycle behavior of the gradient
descent ascend dynamic
and
it's uh very often that these dynamics
do not converge
and
even if we go in a very simple example
like uh if we want to
solve the min max problem where the
objective function is x times y
then running the gradient center the
same dynamics instead of converging to
the mid-march equilibrium of
this problem it diverges away from this
equilibrium or cycles around this
equilibrium
so
our goal is to see how
uh fundamental is uh this problem that
we observe in min maximization
uh or if it's a problem of the methods
that we use in particular gradient set
so
uh let's say we have a next player in y
player we want to solve this min max
problem minimize with respect to x max
minus respect to y of x comma f of x
comma y
and our goal is uh to compare uh this
min max problem with the corresponding
uh single objective problem where we
just have uh one set of variable
set of variables x and one objective f
and we just want to
minimize this objective
so
in the early days of both problems
we assume that the function f
where we assume that the function f is
uh for the minimization problem we
assume that the function f is a convex
function
and for the mean max optimization
problem
we assume that the
function f is convex with respect to x
and y and concave with respect to y
then we have the following theorems so
for
er as well known for
minimization problems we know that first
order methods can find solution
polynomial time
and we also know that there exists other
methods that can find the solutions in
polynomial time for the min max
optimization problem as well again
uh
only for the simpler setting where f is
convex and
in the minimization settings and
comments because in the mid-max
variations
so this behavior for this
of gradient descent in this simple
example
x times y which is
convex concave
is an artifact of the
of the computational methods that we are
using so
uh if we use a more elaborate uh
optimization method and
uh greater descent then we can avoid
this oscillations
uh when
in this simple set
but now let's go to the
other times where the function f is a
non-convex function
that has values in some body detail his
ellipse is continuous and
also the gradient this leaves is
continuous
then what we know about this setting
uh of course even for the minimizations
i think if the function is non-convex
and we
and our goal is to find the global
solutions this is an epic problem
uh we don't hope to find the general
theoretical argument for solving this
problem
but the deep learning approach was
whatever
maybe we're not interested in finding
global solutions but let's go at least
for local optimality
and what we mean by local optimality
uh so a local lot in the minimization
problem is uh very naturally local
minimum of a function f
and the min max optimization problem is
uh just a subtle point of the function f
and uh it's a folklore result that first
order methods can find approximate local
minima
uh in
in a polynomial number of steps and
queries uh
to the function f and the gradient of
this function
uh so
the is is there a corresponding uh
positive result for the mean
maximization for finding local solutions
of minimaxization
and what we saw the
last year with um
uh the scalaxis pulakis is that first
other methods need exponentially many
queries to find def
to find approximate local minimum
exponentially increased to the function
f and its gradient
and
this is an unconditional bound it holds
for any first order method
and first order method will need the
exponential main queries
and in fact any algorithm like first
order second order of whatever needs
super polynomial time unless uh p is
equals vpd which is a complex theoretic
assumption we don't
assume it helps
so this is the first exponential
separation
formal exponential expiration between
these uh
two problems
for which the simple versions the
complex and convex concave versions seem
to have
the same complexity
and just very briefly like the proof
idea for this is
to associate
the local solutions of mid-march
optimization with finding fixed points
of continuous functions
so finding fixed points of continuous
functions
so for any
given continuous function x it aids to
find the points of the h of x star is
equal to x star
is a problem that is um
the existence of such a fixed point is
usually used in many multi-agent
settings in order to show the existence
of equilibrium so it's a very general
problem
uh it's and uh very helpful in many
multi-agent settings
and
it's easy to see that finding min max
local min match points reduces to
finding fixed points so from continuous
functions but what we saw is that this
the difficulty of our proof is to so
that these two problems are accuracy
equivalent
and now what the general directions
looking
the
understanding the complexity of finding
uh fixed points
as opposed to minimizing some potential
is what can lead you to uh more
elaborate arguments for multi-agent um
machine learning methods
and uh
in particular
uh not gonna go into detail but you can
use ideas from algorithms for finding
fixed points to design topological
arguments for mid-march optimization
which at least have asymptotic global
convergence
and um
yeah so this is a general direction that
i'm very interested in to design the
facial implication learning methods for
multi-agent machine learning systems we
have a lot of ongoing work
here in berkeley about that
and
more technically an idea that
i think
will need the
more attention is to defend to the
develop efficient algorithms that are
benzotopological arguments which are
usually the arguments that are used to
prove the fixed point theorems rather
than potential function arguments
and yeah these arguments are
used to show the existence of
exponential debatable
thank you
okay
i cannot hear you saying something